[Music]
I'm inspector Kildare Scotland Yard I'm
investigating a series of deaths they're
calling them the Limehouse and golem
murders
a granted Highway he slaughtered a
household the previous week a prostitute
golems a madman even murders as its own
logic
in spectacled day I may have found an
eyewitness in my mouth sir they can't
tell you what I know just assist me I
promise I won't let him sink I don't
it was here on September the 24th there
were four men that day young Cree Dan
Lena George Gissing Karl Marx the
newspaper said it was your first murder
case
the yard is setting me up as a scapegoat
the public want blood the golem provider
he who observes spills no less blood the
knee who inflicts the blow it's a
message to us how many more people have
to die before the Golem is caught
who keep my secret and I'll keep yours
the golems start large wasting my time
could cost lives
[Music]
I believe the golem is after me our
shelf stoppers I guarantee we all wear
antemer masks doing
[Music]
[Music]